we make way for the Hall of Fame coach
John Thompson working for Westwood One
NCAA radial color analyst and he joins
us the Continental Tire Coaches Corner
good morning coach good to have you on
board how you feeling thanks verified
how would you sum up this Final Four Wow
well you know I think it's been very
exciting because they've done a lot of
things that occur that folks didn't
expect to occur you know we went through
the whole process of the season which I
think you know antiquated because I
don't think that anybody gets into this
tournament who can't play it's just that
they've been unseen but I think it's
been very exciting is the three good for
college basketball
it's the three-point shot good for
college basketball well you know I mean
I think it probably is is good and it's
not going anywhere but you know I didn't
like it when it came in personally
because you know I thought you should
get more points for being able to make a
layup than for hitting the jump shot you
know and but that's my bias and it's
about the inside game but I think it has
been exciting and I certainly believe
that Villanova would believe that isn't
Alaska but should we move it to the
international line as opposed it feels
like college the three is a little too
easy whereas maybe international would
be a little fairer distance your
thoughts on them well with the Rangers
these kids have now where the hell they
either move it I these guys if you see
and you know that you've seen this stuff
enough that these guys are shooting
further and further back you know and
even the girls game now they're shooting
deep shots so people keep talking about
moving their back how far back are we go
movie
how would you coach now with the three
well you know it depends on which team
you're playing against and the reason
Villanova the problem is that they have
five guys that can hit the three but
usually you can
SEDOL for somebody and put the emphasis
on the person who is the 3-point shooter
or the persons but it's highly unusual
that you get five guys that are capable
of shooting or even guys coming on for
the bench so it's very difficult to just
say how you would defend against it
predicated or who you have on your team
who's capable of making that you have to
make certain adjustments where do you
stand on the one in Dunn room whoa well
you know I find it very difficult to be
for it and I find it difficult to be
against it in some ways because I think
a person is entitled to make a living to
this table or making a living
but the myth of it is is that they're
not so many people who are qualified for
leave in college or we talk about it as
if everybody's a superstar you know but
I think it hurts more kids than it helps
it only helps the kids who should be
going one and done but there's so many
kids today who think that it's a status
sign and they leave school and they find
themselves not educated they found
themselves poor they find themselves in
trouble so you know it's a hard one for
me but I just think you should be able
to if you try to leave school be able to
return I think it's a big thing what
about coming out of high school like you
know I'm old school with that you know I
just have a problem you know with that
because I mean you might be able to play
basketball but you sure are vulnerable
to be exploited you know you know the
thing about all of this that bothers me
is that folks talk about it like there's
no value in an education certainly a
person should as I just said have the
ability to make a living who can make a
living but there is a value I'm so sick
of hearing people say that you know they
play basketball for nothing you know the
education is pretty doggone valuable to
some folks you know and it should be
valuable to them
they're not able to make the league so
all of this stuff is great if somebody
can tell you the solution to how to
resolve it of the kids who are not good
we talked to Patrick Ewing in San
Antonio and I said if you were playing
now would you be one and done he said
yes
how could you would you keep him I mean
you would understand his greatness but
as his coach you know that that fine
line between you know is it better for
you to stay one more year or is it
better for you to go into the NBA how
would you have approached that with
Patrick so you're hitting on exactly
what I was alluding to before you know
what I was telling if they asked me
should he leave I would say no they
asked me does he have to leave I would
say yes you know Missy in that side I
talked to a kid not too long ago and I
just would prefer not to use his name
and his dad said to me should my son
leave school I told him no I said but
he's got to go because he was assured of
being paid he was assured of the amount
of money that possibly he could make and
you know as well as I know that next
year they might evaluate him totally
different and he would have lost out on
the money so Patrick most definitely and
I said that the Patrick Alonzo Dikembe
Allen and all of the kids that I had who
I thought would go early that if they
were playing in today's rascal ball that
they would have left school right away
or probably would not have come but
that's why it's not just a clear picture
you've got to know the circumstances
that the kid exists under he's John
Thompson Hall of Fame coach joining his
Continental Tire Coach's Corner best
player you coached against was who I met
that I coached against yeah oh boy
probably all of those that beat me well
you know how I would say oh god that's a
Harlan you know Ralph Sampson has got to
be one of them you know because at the
time with what I had and I had Patrick
Patrick was a freshman at the time and
Ralph wasn't extremely you know talented
player but
I've coached against a lot of very very
fine players in my career and I don't
know that I can just pinpoint one other
than looking at his abilities at agility
his size his intelligence I would almost
say Ralph Sampson right now
did you know Jordan's greatness when you
were coaching against him I don't think
anybody anybody who says they knew
Jordans greatness is lying you know I
don't think anybody knew they knew that
he was good you know you know I told
Michael that when he hit the last shot
against us we were garden worthy we
thought we're having with one who was
gonna make the basket and he fusses at
me about Elias when he sees me he said
yeah you don't you know didn't think I
was that good there I said you have to
lose the correct we thought we had
packed in this not worthy but well
Michael I think just got better and
better and better he was very good no
don't let me mislead you with that but
there's no way and I've talked to Dean
before and being knew that Michael was
good but it's no way that you can
predict that anybody is gonna be as good
as those great great players I mean
would did I think that Kobe would yes I
thought probably was a good player but I
didn't think he would be as good as Kobe
and Michael certainly you know I didn't
think would be what Michael has become
did you be crude Kody you know I wanted
to recruit homies but I knew that we
didn't have you know an opportunity to
get him based on the schools that were
probably interested in him at the time
you get a feel for it there I mean once
you start to recruit a player you found
out his interest you know who's after
him you know in that kind of thing what
I'd like to hack Kobe is the question
he's damn right I was I said last time
you had the itch to coach that's a good
one
I always I have the it's the coach man I
just don't have the itch to end the
practice games coach excuse me if you
just did games instead of the
Shona pontus oh hell I'd be like
everybody else and coaches to use
without going to practice yeah you know
you got all you got to do is walk over
here to the final floor and you talk to
a little old lady you know sister Jean
comes easy from there I prefer to prep
the preparation the preparation and you
know that the preparation for the game
is probably one of the most difficult
things that I found and when I got to
the point of feeling it was me and not
the kids I said it's time to get the
hell out of here you know with it and it
comes to that point particularly the
practices because you have to get
involved with so many personal things as
well as getting involved with the game
itself and but as far as the game is
concerned if I could just show up for
the game and coach and coach the game
heck I could do that now did you keep
any of those towels that you would
always have on your shoulder no I didn't
keep any special one you know and I got
that from my mom in the kitchen you know
people ask me about the towel you know I
had the towel on my shoulder before I
realized it was on my shoulder because I
did it eventually I mean my mom worked
around the house she'd always have a
towel over shoulders and I started doing
it until people started to say you know
what he's walking around people walk up
to me that today and ask me where's the
towel no idea where the towel was I
didn't have one special work well guide
Lewis had a special one right he had
that that that chequered towels it and
he would have he did injury talk use
always not one that he bid on the tool
on it you know and those are the things
you know you do sometimes without
realizing it and then it becomes a habit
and most athletes very superstitious
most coaches aver if I want a big game
and knew I had you know a towel on my
shoulder you can believe me I wouldn't
take the power off again give me the
most important player for each team
tonight I don't think it's the most
important player to tell you the truth
I think it's their systems both of these
themes are here because of how well they
execute themselves you know Villanova
certainly which seems to be everybody's
favorite and Michigan the same thing
that you know they're they're in a
situation with a very systematic you
know I don't think that this game will
come down to you know just what one
player certainly one players will
contribute but I just think that these
are will all the machines they're great
clinic teams that you will sit down and
look at and demonstrate the kids that
this is how you play basketball they're
unselfish they play together and you
know that they definitely of that way
can you clear up something before I let
you go people talk about Villanova
beating you guys in 1985 is the greatest
upset in college basketball history I
argue that Villanova was a whole lot
better than people realized and they'd
played you twice during the regular
season and I and I think that they were
competitive games close games your
thoughts on how we should define that
win by villeneuve over Georgetown well
it was a great win for good know that
goes what I was saying but you 100%
correct we played them three times beat
them twice and the two times have we
beat them before they beat us there was
one a two point game so you know they
say it or described it as if it was
something that was impossible for
Villanova to do you know do I think we
had a better team yes I definitely think
we had a better team but I think
Virginia's got a better team than
anybody in the tournament you know when
when you're in a one-game situation you
know a lot of it depends on how you're
playing how they're playing you know at
that time Villanova shot the ball all
the way almost the way villain in that
game
Villanova shot the ball almost the way
to Villanova shooting the ball right now
so you know it definitely I don't want
to take anything away from that victory
but I'll tell you what you know with
Virginia losing I'm so sick of hearing
people talk about the Villanova the most
upset you know although I feel terrible
I feel absolutely terrible that my whole
tournament feelings have been with
Virginia because I know that kind of
thing can happen but if you go through
that body at work they play better than
anybody in the country and then total
body at work and then you lose one ball
game because things just don't fall in
place but you see how I avoided the
Villanova game and me did you watch the
film in that game you know what that's a
damn good question
people don't believe this I've never
watched it never watched it you know the
film of that game again and that's just
one of those things that you know you
get involved and I guess I'm gonna get
mature enough you know to look at it one
day but no I've never watched it yeah
that doesn't sound like you say you know
I don't know I got a couple of hours
here right let me let me
you know cheer up and watch the 85
Villanova game definitely don't feel
that way you know that I want to be
excited about I kid roellig are dressing
that you know I've talked a lot well you
know when he was alive and I'd kid him
about it he'd give me about the game
various strategies that we employ but we
knew in their respect reach each one's
ability but but I think what happens a
lot of times is that folks need to have
an underdog you know that you need to
have that's why University of Maryland
was so significant to people because
they hadn't heard about them and then
won and you know that kind of thing but
that goes along with the sport it's not
something I sit around moan about and
worry about we we lost the Villanova
this man absolutely not I just don't
want to see it hey coach great to talk
to you again have fun tonight and thanks
for joining us
I will you're welcome thanks for having
me that's John Thompson Hall of Fame
coach Westwood one n-c-double-a color
analyst he'll be on the call Continental
Tire Coach's Corner whether you're a
student alumni are all-around fan
Continental Tire has a tire that can get
you to the big game they are a proud
supporter of thirty two college
basketball teams across the United
States Continental Tire shares your
passion for the game show them your
passion using hashtag Oda bask
for more information visit condon entire
calm for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]